welcome back everybody
apologies hopefully you people
can still see us while we're covering
the magnus scouts
versus vladislav artemyev match where
magnus carson
has a demanding lead
up four in the bullet section last the
last game
and now there's a sharp position on the
board peter svidler
what's going on well magnus is
uh going to win this because there's not
going to be enough time but our team
did win the previous one the one where
we were saying that white never has
enough
enough time to mount any kind of
comeback and black gets
all the mating threats in first but uh
our team have won that very very easily
and it's probably doing quite well in
this one as well
uh demanding lead i meant commanding
you did but uh maybe he is
demanding we acknowledge his leaders as
being extremely commanding
[Music]
so witty where do you learn to speak
english so well peter
see i silenced peter yeah i've uh
simple compliment you you broke me with
that yeah it's uh
it doesn't take very much these days to
completely break me rook c3 now it's a
it's a fun position it's a pity that
there's so little intrigue left in
uh in the match because uh
[Music]
the last couple of games were quite
exciting and if the the score was at
least a little bit closer we would have
had a
uh a lot more a lot more fun with this
okay now our team just leaves the knight
and pries which is
uncalled for and magnus doesn't take on
e4 this is like
slightly copical honestly uh what's
happening here queen takes e4 was not a
bad move on the previous move
you have to say and uh
slightly earlier but doesn't matter yeah
artemis is i mean the sun game is
probably technically winning now
which will bring the scorp to -3 which
is still
way too much hanging around with the
time remaining
magnus did look like he was in
a good horse only jumps as high as it
has to jump mode today
yeah it did feel like that certainly and
uh
it's uh hard to blame him for that
either it's a
it's an understandable feeling when
you're so far so far ahead when the
bullet portion starts but
yeah for for us as viewers obviously
it's a bit regrettable that it's not
closer
[Music]
yeah what's more exciting than a close
match
um yeah just like this the world
champion
will most likely advance to the
semi-finals there he will face maxima
sheila graf
his potential opponent in the next
classical world championship match as
well so
that's a treat to look forward to and
also
in half an hour on this very
channel there will be coverage of the
nakamura
against fiduciary afghan match by the
great peter laco
and the great tanya sachdev
so there is so much chess today
to still look forward to it's almost a
pity peter
that you will spend the next eight hours
playing hearthstone
i will watch season three of the
bachelorette in german because i
finished the current season
what are we doing with our lives well
exactly what you've described and
neither of us appear to be complaining
although i i'm complaining
yeah i'm also going apparently i've
complained to almost 500 times and i
think
if i actually hit the 500 mark the world
ends so
i should probably you know work on
achieving a sunnier disposition post
haste
i don't know how to get there though
magnus actually is running the clock
down in this one that's a bit unexpected
oh
professional
queen g7 very precise mate next move
he's thinking about it
[Music]
he actually is thinking about it like
that's uh
that's some that's some bm right there
uh i did not expect to see that honestly
i
i think the it's not it's not close
enough to demand he
you know wastes the entirety of the last
10 seconds there but
what do i know maximizing the ev is what
all the best players do apparently
ulti optimal is saying with peter and
tanya's whole business
there you go you'll get strictly
business like
epmd in the next session
and our shenanigans will
disappear like kaiser sauce
if you want to distract peter lako
though
i'll give you a few pro tips ask him
about wrestling particularly like
late 90s like bret hart when the wwe was
still called wwf
he will he will share strong opinions
or you could also ask him about
jean-claude
van damme movies i once lost a
name van damme movies of against peter
lako
and i'm amazing at naming van damme
movies
i i've watched quite a lot when i was
younger but
uh i've given up but piroleco
you've seen them all yeah when i was
actually watching them i
i didn't really speak english yet and i
had no access to original movies so i
would know the names in
you play that poor soviet union card
again
just yes accepting my superior van damme
no no i i do accept it i'm just saying
that um
[Music]
i can't really time cop what
that's a van damme movie probably is
though yeah
bloodsport and bloodsport too and
potentially even bloodsport three right
i'm not even sure but
was there what sport three was van damme
and bloodsport too
even that is unclear yeah this is i'm
more of a
michael dudikov kind of guy ah there i
can't compete
michael dulikov was that american ninja
yeah yeah that that i am not there
literally no nothing other than that
that type of franchise yeah
[Music]
dr sausage is saying how many jcvt
movies have you seen the
theater i remember watching hard targets
in the theater there was a time when you
could still smoke
in movie theaters and i happened to be a
smoker then
it was very exciting i smoked a lot of
cigarettes
and yeah that's a very distinct memory
from my childhood i was like nine at the
time but yeah it's
a highly recommended movie too stood the
test of time
hard targets uh
yeah it's about rich people
hunting humans for sports
like uh the what was that that movie
that
uh that there was a lot of uh
controversy was supposed to be released
last year
about rich people hunting people for
sport and uh
the people they were hunting for sport
were all for some reason republicans
the hunt yeah i think it was just called
the hunt right yeah
i've seen that one too yeah it wasn't
wasn't as thrilled as when i watched
heart target
that's probably because you weren't
smoking at the time right no comment
no probably not probably not
[Laughter]
fair enough uh anyway magnus wins the
one uh the one with black and now
appears completely in the clear as if we
didn't know that before
and uh we get another lesson in this
weird quintex d4 queen e3
uh sicilian yeah all the cool kids are
doing this now magnus live on
and that's the list i don't think any
other cool kids
any other cool kids are actually doing
that but those those two are
about us those two are the bullies in
chess camp
yeah jay glones is asking if peter's
allowed a computer to play hearthstone
during the standard games
i might assume at this point it's in
your contract right pretty much yeah i
used to i remember
in the in the younger years i would
occasionally ask the arbiter to open a
quick info page with the
with the current match of the day open
there and i would
occasionally like during the game go and
check the score
and the arbiters would kind of kind of
uh
agree to that which thinking about it
now they probably shouldn't that's
probably a violation of
you know very very wrong yeah but
uh you know where's the harm
[Music]
it sets a dangerous precedent where does
it end
yeah and when does this end
soon so new probably this is the last
game any any time now
how does it go yeah any day now any day
now
i shall be released
[Music]
with a yeah that's uh i'm not even sure
if that's originally a dylan song
dylan actually dylan definitely sang
that but i don't know if that's
originally dylan
probably is
[Music]
i i have a chest related memory actually
connected with that song
and i was when i was in my in my 20s
music played a much
bigger role in my like everyday life and
i had this really annoying habit of
writing down sort of the lyric of the
day on the scoresheet
uh so my my scoresheets in those years
they all bore
a testament to what i sort of what was
playing in my head on repeat on the day
and there was different there were
definitely tournaments where any day now
any day now i shall be released was
was very much the mood of the day and i
was kind of
those were normally not very cheerful
games
when that was the song of the day um
yeah i'm still not sure what we're
talking about this is dylan separate
yeah yeah i've always been more of a
brandon and brenda
[Music]
magnus plundered another piece he really
was yeah he he wants out of there he
he is not really in any way enthused
about any of this but
he's probably gonna hold this one too
they might both
not be too thrilled about this match
today
but the world champion did come through
which is all that matters in the end
well i'm not sure if it's all that
matters but
it's all that matters in terms of
staying in the tournament
yeah although i think money-wise i'm not
sure how much this matters to magnus but
there is a
difference depending on the margin you
score
in the matches right you score a higher
percentage yeah i think i think there is
there is some additional incentive to
win to win big and uh yeah the margin
feels like could have been bigger today
uh could also have been smaller if our
team if used all
the chances he had in the in the earlier
portions the bullet
didn't really feel like magnus wasn't in
any trouble at any point but
there were definitely a number of blown
chances by artemis earlier
all right so the world champion wins the
match
what's the final score 13.59 is that
accurate
seems to be accurate yeah googlegamer123
is asking young are you an influencer
i do consider myself an influencer so
far i do not yet get paid
for influencing people on what products
to buy
but i am highly influential especially
in the
rice cooker opinion business i have been
asked
many a time what rice cooker i prefer
so magnus moves on sorry sorry go ahead
no i was
by many a time i was going to say that
that's uh how many a time like seven
times
that is actually a well a larger number
than i anticipated hearing
when i asked you that question it was a
very respectable number
yeah yeah there's been well it's a bit
of a running joke
in the german chess 24 community the
rice cooker stuff
so yeah it's it's fun shows you guys
should learn german and stuff by
we talk about rice cookers about
um german cuisine it's all the good
stuff
i was gonna start a word but i failed so
over to you peter
yeah i'm gonna say this was um even
though our
you know our relationship has been uh uh
exposed by the the sleuth in the chess
24 chat and
we no longer have you know the option of
continuing the pretense of everything
being happy and
and shiny but this this still was uh a
fun in a
perverted sort of way but we do now have
to set up the stage for the
the next pair the the actual shiny
people
so thanks everybody for watching the the
next match
we could stick around what do you have
to do we have like
20 minutes until they come yeah but if
we
if we don't locate the premises they
might never come
that's the i think so we should ask so
tears our producer
he actually needs time to set them up in
which case
alternatively you could listen to what
serious has already told us on the topic
i'm not reading the chat everyone knows
anyway fira is saying i also bought a
rice cooker thanks to jan's opinion
there you go there you go
big rice if you're watching just saying
i do have the power
to direct people certain ways so i would
not want to be left behind
in the rice cooker wars of 2020.
you might need a powerful ally all i'm
saying
thank you so much peter this has been
fun not for magnus or artemiev
or the viewers but who cares about any
of them
except magnus because i think he can
probably get me fired
potentially yeah and maybe even me yeah
even though i'm not technically speaking
employed but he still probably could get
me fired
i think so too yeah
bye everybody thank you so much for
watching enjoy nakamura against
fedo save another big match don't sleep
on
fedor say f because it would probably
hurt him and also he's a very very
strong test player
this will be a close enough match
so watch that peter lako will be there
make sure to ask peter about wrestling
jean-claude van damme movies any trunkle
van damme movies doesn't have to be
lionheart or the obvious ones the quest
he's seen it don't you work thanks
everybody
bye cheers